welcome to this video playing Machado
okay so let's see some kind of kings in
here and going for the field cheto
variation for variety's sake you're not
very interested in maybe learning it for
real what have those days one of those
days I think it's probably a line that
should smite star very well but if not
yet studied it okay he's trying for 95
okay I probably have to do this anyway
at some point I was really wondering if
I should take on c5 here or not and
since not really clear that an ego is
one terribly taking I didn't expect that
one okay so he wants to go to c5 and
play f4 and f5 I'm sorry hmm interesting
maybe him he can take with them with the
with the bishop but now okay no it's not
happening probably I have to take it
anyway so I cannot allow him to play a 4
here we see why I went g3 a tree I mean
age three well that was quickly decided
I have to cover g3 in this kind of
structure so Bishop deform and this is
also structure that is very well known
to be better for why turn I'm a bit
curious why he is going for that
willingly I'm just going right to e3
Bishop over to e2 and prepare g4 at the
end of end of it and yeah I don't think
that this is leading to anything night
coming 23 I will have bishop f1 maybe
it's God be five which is very weird
looking but hmm maybe maybe it's not
completely off
it would be the only way to justify what
he's doing playing be five but see what
is he doing now just going back on and
so let's look at this age five porn it's
covering that yeah quite usually white
is going with g4 yeah I'm not sure if
this is the position for that you will
take F takes and F voice hanging kind of
question already ok I'm going on ok I'm
going to have to that that's not bad
anyway and see what happens from here I
mean age voice is no move anyway I think
I'm going to prepare this before move ok
one route DB one before each voice is
not helping him in any way i'm still not
threatening this SB 3 is hanging and
really but at the end i have look a 7 so
okay it's not paying any attention to
that as usual it's kind of kind of used
to being ignored
what's the dealer you have to check on
v3 anyway or not
I mean that cannot move the night away
maybe 93 what no now now this is this
too much come on this is too much a
force also weakness now let's see how to
do that maybe even g4 justjust you for
here hmm it's probably already pretty
strong let's do it
I go f5 King I've form take the Jeep on
take the e pawn and hopefully win this
game I'd be some little shocking really
check
so what is he trying to do maybe Knight
to e5 or something it looks it continues
at least it's not just blunder to some
City tactic that's the only way to not
win this position now but always always
possible Adly this when I'm playing so
look H for something is he doing this or
look look on the second tier kingi for
was a mistake i should play drew cage
one and then it's basically over and
this isn't that easy now Rudy isn't chad
it's got to cut the active rook look on
the second-ranked seemed more dangerous
but I don't know I don't know
interesting yeah and I have to how
interesting so what happens here Jay
okay i can actually do this so what is
what is wrong with this and it's got to
check here just look aged one earlier
and this this game is over check now
we're better again just picking up the
airport check check
Jeff
check check check
16 seconds don't things even trying to
stop the porn check check check check
check check check check mate ok yeah
sometimes the games have a half the
writer right result but really am great
at screwing those completely winning
positions up especially this this kind
of thing here wash is picking up
everything I just have to play rook edge
one just at one point book edge one and
nothing happens here anymore and he's
never getting his rook active this is
the the big difference now now I'm
winning the e porn and just promote the
F porn this is nothing nothing happens
here and here again Luke to h1 and ok
sorry G for saying so Bishop h5 or
something just just not this and now it
is getting tricky but rook h2 is far
more far trickier I guess
okay sunglass legging Chan so we had
this no he went here yeah no Rugare for
you just should take the draw he is lost
again check pretty clearly because the a
porn is dropping there was really no
justification doing that chan chan this
is to really just losing because a
tortoise is going to drop out Jackie
Chan and then my a porn fiend will
promote yeah he made a couple of
surprising decisions I was surprised at
that for once but ok it's not a big deal
here plane tix I was actually thinking
he would go here and this this and maybe
oops maybe consider to take with the
bishop it's that's interesting i think
with some ideas sometimes on d3 ok Queen
d7 he took with the porno ever and this
position time is some it's just okay for
white I mean I should be somewhat better
here it's funny stock fish is also not
understanding of the position gives
black a slight advantage this is just
wrong I mean I tend to get flagged for
calling stockfish wrong yeah the
computer is not perfect you know it
still does not understand position types
and why does not worse yet or just the
question of how much advantage does he
have yeah getting my knight to e three
and he's got a very bad bishop and I
always have g4 in the long run the
computers especially tend to over
evaluate protected passes like this this
is really nothing special
chill here I'm very comfortable but the
thing is what he played it just makes
some kind of sense if he goes be five
but he didn't do that he just played age
five and went back so it's kind of nice
bringing the king over and now I went
for this preparation of before I should
play before he actually I only later
really understood that in this kind of
situation he cannot really take it
anyway because of Luke a seven with
white shaking c7 and here I mean he has
to take is really and then go somewhere
to d3 this must be some kind of he has
to justify this dynamically 97's is some
basically losing I think I don't think
don't see black coming back for them
that is exactly exactly what what
happened in the game mr. is the result
of this this passive position we have
those two points will drop and a4 is a
permanent weakness as we have seen later
okay well thanks for watching